first there was planet Earth then there  was planet good I  we see the young rookie Jared Goff in  his natural habitat  tossing and turning nervously in the  confines of his own bed this quarterback  is of particular interest as he was  drafted as the very best of them all  other rookies have already started to  make long strides and even middling  newcomers are learning their place now  it is time for our youngster to leave  the nest and prove himself the league's  top defenders lie in wait for the  rookies for a step the little Goff has  lost his footing  this is newborn escaping snakes baby Ram  is booked to slaughter the defenders  feast  next time on planet gridiron here we see  a walrus relaxing in the warm water oh  wait no that's coach Andy Reid taking a  bath